hi everyone uh welcome to the class so
um um jhuan covered the topics around
graph neural networks over the last few
weeks uh but now I'm kind of uh I'm back
and I'm going to cover uh uh for uh some
of some of the next topics so here is
what we'll talk today about without any
bugs uh we so far talked about graph
neural networks and um how to handle
graphs with a single type of relation
and then in the in the um the last
lecture we then talked about
heterogeneous graphs and how do you
build gnns for heterogeneous graphs um
we talked about the relational gcn the
knowledge gra um we talked about the
relational gcn in the last graph so in
the last lecture what are we going to do
today we are going to talk about
knowledge graphs which are these
directed graphs with different relation
types that usually have no features on
nodes um of the of the network and what
we are kind of going to talk to today
about is kind of an analog of note to
wack and deep walk that we this kind of
shallow embeddings that we talked about
um at the beginning uh of the class uh
and generalize that to uh to
heterogeneous graphs that's one way to
uh think of this and the task we'll be
talking about is the embeddings for
Knowledge Graph completion that's the
way to think of this so
last time sorry sorry sorry okay so last
time we talked about heterogeneous
graphs we talked about graphs with
different notes types and different
relation types yes there's no hour on
announcement page ignore everything I
said so far okay sorry sorry it was the
wrong slides that's why it was in
October that's all everything is wrong
sorry sorry sorry okay so brand new
lecture breed in look you guys are the
best you arrived
later you won't be confused so if you
are confused ask them okay so brand new
lecture start from scratch ignore
everything I said really sorry um going
again so these are the announcements
that are good read them um they've been
verified this is the cs224w machine
learning with graphs today we are going
to talk about knowledge graphs embedding
so the topic is right okay so what did
we talk about last um um last time we
talked about uh how do we generalize
graph neural networks to heterogeneous
graphs where we have edges of different
types and we have nodes um potentially
of different types okay um and we talked
about relational gcn where we learn um a
graph from um basically we learn from a
graph with multiple relation types and
we use different neural network weights
for different relation types right so we
basically took the GNN architecture but
generalized it now so that this Mage
message passing functions are relation
specific so that we have more expressive
power um when working with heterogeneous
graphs today we are going to kind of
take this and further generalizes
generalize it to the notion of knowledge
graphs and let me first tell you what is
a Knowledge Graph and why is it so
important and why is it so useful so
knowledge graphs allow you to capture in
a graph form in a relational form uh
knowledge about entities uh and their
relations so we are going to capture
entities types and the relationships
between them so you can think of nodes
as entities and uh node types are and
these nodes are lab labeled with their
types and then edges between two nodes
capture the relationship between the
entities um and knowledge graph is an
example of a heterogeneous graph but the
reason why we call these things
knowledge graphs because the idea is
that we encode our knowledge about a
given domain in this type of graphical
form so you can think of this as a
knowledge base over which you can reason
over which you can retrieve and allows
you to kind of bring in the knowledge to
your machine learning model okay so
that's the that's the idea so what would
be one example of a knowledge graph for
example if you are answering questions
predictions about Academia and papers
then for example a bibliographic Network
you can think of it as a Knowledge Graph
right you have conferences papers titles
year of public ations and authors and
papers have citations to each other so
this is like a schema of this
heterogeneous Knowledge Graph with five
different Noe types and five different
uh relation types okay and now I'm
basically encoding all I know about uh
all the Publications ever published
another example especially um that is
extremely useful is um biom medicine
where again you have a lot of different
entities you know from drugs to diseases
uh Adverse Events proteins Pathways and
you want to kind of encode this
knowledge in a graphical form so here we
have different types of relations like
is a so kind of hierarchical
associations between different things
treatment that a given drug treats for a
given disease a a drug may cause a
adverse side effect of migraine in this
case and you can kind of build this
knowledge graph scaffold that you can
use as a a knowledge base over which you
can then uh reason or over which you can
then learn and there's many other uh
knowledge graphs that I I'm going to
show you later for example Google
answers a Knowledge Graph when when you
type questions into the Google search
box uh same same same same with Amazon
Amazon has a knowledge graph of all
their products their properties Sellers
and all that is in some sense their
knowledge base like Facebook calls is
the Facebook Graph API if you want
access Facebook um as a graph right if
you look at Facebook it's in in a sense
it's not only people and their
relationships but also um the what what
schools people went to what locations
they attended uh that's all nodes in
this knowledge graph it's all resolved
to the level of entities um you know and
there are other um examples of these
Technologies from IBM Watson to to
Microsoft has its own they call it sator
um you know LinkedIn Yandex and so on
and so forth and just give you one
example of the application is for
serving information right when you ask
let's say here Bing right what are the
latest uh um films by the director of
Titanic they actually par this go go to
the go to the um go to the uh go to the
knowledge graph uh find the director and
then look at what is this director
linked by uh by the relation that they
directed what movies they directed and
that's how they uh retrieve right and
usually if you think about um uh
question answering let's say systems if
you think of Siri if you think of Alexa
they are powered uh by the by the
structured knowledge in the in the
background right so Siri uses a
humongous knowledge graph of the world's
knowledge that when you ask it a
question the think queries right and
gives you the answer and right here I'm
showing you um an example of a um
architecture of this kind of
conversational um question answering
system where uh you know where the the
language natural language understanding
is only a part of this and in particular
what the key part is to take this
language pars it into a set of um uh
candidates that you are then retrieving
from the knowledge graphs uh and then
returning back uh to the user so that's
kind of the key in this case so today
right we are going to talk about this uh
knowledge graphs and if you think about
general knowledge knowledge graphs then
free base wiky data dbpedia are examples
of this right if you can take an entire
Wikipedia and you can represent it as a
as a graph of nodes and their properties
and relations between them Freebase is
another example of this this was I think
a project that Google acquired um couple
of years ago for for for a lot I think I
think the the price was are was in
billions right um and what is common
characteristics to these things is that
they are massive they have millions of
nodes uh millions of different edges and
relations and they are really incomplete
uh in a sense that knowledge has not
been completely mapped in this uh
knowledge graphs usually the reason
there is two ways one is we haven't
entered all the knowledge in uh and the
second the second reason is we haven't
yet discovered all the knowledge if you
think about bio bi medicine biomedical
knowledge graphs are incomplete because
we don't understand fully the bi the
let's say human biology so clearly there
is information we are missing because we
haven't discovered it yet versus uh a
Knowledge Graph like Freebase I'll show
you later 83% of people that appear in
free Bay as nodes don't have a year of
birth I think is the statistic right
because we haven't yet nobody added that
information in yet right so given what
we'll be talking today about um um
uh you know kind of given a massive
Knowledge Graph enumerating all possible
facts becomes intractable but what we
would like to do is the question is can
we predict plausible but missing links
uh in this knowledge graphs or can we
somehow embed nodes in the knowledge
graph to to show you right I said
earlier a prominent example of knowledge
graphs is free base this kind of encodes
knowledge about you know this kind of uh
commonly known entity
and that appear in the world it's about
80,000 80 million entities 38,000
different relation types right so there
is 38,000 different Edge types and three
billion
edges right so because by the relation
so the point is it's not five relation
types it's 83,000 different relation
types right so the World Knowledge in
the structured structured forum is um is
uh is um is very complex right as I said
um 93% of people in that appear in free
base don't have a place of birth um and
80% don't have a nationality right so
there is no link relationship of that
person uh nationality and to the let's
say country or Nation mapped explicitly
in this knowledge graph yes I guess when
you're recording data in these knowledge
graphs is it preferable to have like
proliferation of relation types like
lots of relation types or is it more
useful to have grouping of relation
types from a learning perspective uh
good point so what you are asking is to
say you have like here I emphasized you
have this huge number of relation types
right and the question is is that too is
that too much um what should you what
what should you do right I would say
there is an entire um how to say
industry or an entire field of you know
how do you build onology
how do you build this knowledge basis
and it becomes very very tricky how do
you how do you bring any structure to
this 38,000 different uh relationships
and usually what would happen is that
you would have them in some kind of
hierarchy if possible where this
relationships would get more and more
fine grain but still allows you to kind
of Reason between different uh
relationship types so that becomes quite
important um in terms of publicly
available data sets that people like to
use there is this free base 15,000 which
is a graph on 50,000 entities about
between 200 and 1,300 different
relations and about 300,000 to 600,000
uh different edges right so if you want
a kind of a little academic B Benchmark
this is what you know news papers T to
use but really the full data set is up
here very few papers kind of have the
have the guts to use the big data set
because it's massive um but that's the
that's the idea so now what we will so
now let's we talked about this knowledge
graph um kind of uh uh concept now let's
talk about what is the knowledge graph
completion task that people like to do
so a Knowledge Graph completion task is
defined as follows given an enormous
Knowledge Graph the question is can we
complete it right so given it's almost
like a link prediction task but it's a
bit it's a bit more nuanced and this
link prediction task for Knowledge Graph
says given a head and a relation type
predict me the missing Tales right so it
would be for a particular person for a
particular relation type maybe born in R
give me a list of places where that
person might have been born because a
single person can be born only in one
place I'd only take the top one right
but in other cases maybe it's be like
visited you know tell me all the places
that Napoleon visited then it' be a
ranking and somewhere I would I would
cut that right so um one example of the
task would be you know for the for the
um predict the tail right like you would
predict science fiction for the head
entity KJ KJ Rowling and the J and and
the John relation is the the question is
what is the taale of this of this query
it would be science fiction or it would
be I don't know the youth literature or
however you want to however you want to
call it so that's what we would like to
be able to do and as I said it's a bit
different than Link Link prediction
because I'm given the head and the
relation type so now as I mentioned in
the beginning of the lecture the way we
are going to do this is we are going to
learn a shallow embedding of the notes
so it means that for every node in the
knowledge graph we are going to learn
its coordinates um in a shallow way so
we will not be using gnns but we are
kind of moving back to this idea of
shallow embeddings um deep walks and and
and uh deep walk and no to back but as
you will see we will not be using random
walks so we'll just be using shallow and
bearings so in terms of um uh Knowledge
Graph representation the way we think of
it is that it's a set of these triples
head relation tail um and the idea is
that we want to model entities and
relations as embeddings or vectors in
some ukian space right and we want to
associate entities and relations with
shallow embeddings uh right as I said
no no gnns the reason perhaps why no
gnns is because these knowledge graphs
usually have no note features maybe you
have a note type but not more right so
the the the all the information is in
relations so then the idea will be given
a true triple head relation tail the
goal is to find the embedding for the
head relation that is close to the
embedding of the of the target okay so
we'll be kind of talking about
embeddings of you I will give you a head
and I'll give you a relation you will
find you will produce me an embedding of
this thing and hopefully the embedding
of this thing will be close to the
embedding of the target so that the
answer to this query is this target
that's that's that's the Hope okay so uh
the question then is how do you embed
this thing and how do you define
closeness okay what is interesting
notice right I'm not embedding just a
node I'm embedding node comma relation
and I'd like to that this embedding no
not comma relation in the space is close
to the answer to this right the correct
thing has to be close to where the
embedding of this head comma relation is
so what we are going to do today is we
are going to learn about different
methods to Pro produce embeddings of
knowledge graphs as well as uh the
relations that are in them this
embeddings will be shallow so we'll kind
of work in the transductive uh case we
are going to use
different geometric kind of ukian
geometry type intuitions um and we are
going to talk about different types of
relationships that our embeddings will
be able to cap to capture we'll talk
about four different methods transy
transs are this mol and complex it
doesn't matter yet what they are I'm
going to Define it doesn't matter what
exactly this means but basically we are
going then to look at different types of
relations we'll talk about symmetric
relations anti-symmetric relations
inverse relations composite relations
and one to end relations I'm going to uh
explain this and we are going to see how
different method is able to embed
different types of relations that's kind
of how what is going to happen and the
rest of the lecture will be will go
through this table line by line and uh
you know we are going kind of to fill in
this uh check marks and um and Crosses
uh for each of these things so at the
end basically
this uh table will be filled in and it
will make uh it will make sense so the
first method I want to talk about is the
first line of my table here is the is
the trans Z okay um are there any
questions before we jump
in yes I mean just based on our
definition where we're taking the head
the relation and then the target is like
the thing we trying to predict it's kind
of like saying that the graph is like is
like directed right right cuz we're
always saying there's a direction from
graph Edge that already gives you
directions toward a Target so a relation
to yes you can great point so you're are
asking is is the graph directed yeah you
can think of it direct that it's
directed but if we are brothers then I
have a link brother to you but you can
also have a link brother to me right so
so yes we are talking about directed
graphs but some relations can go both
ways as as we are going to see okay so
that will be one of the kind of
properties uh that we are going to talk
about okay super so here is the the the
trans z um intuition and it's really
about this transation intuition right
where the idea is for the Triple head
relation tail um I would like the
following kind of in my in my Vector
space in Myan space I'd Like H + r to be
kind of equal to T right um and if the
given facts are true and otherwise I'd
like this uh to kind of be different
okay that's the ition so the way the way
this would look like is to say the
embedding of an H comma R is that I take
the embedding of H I have some embedding
for R so I move in this direction and
hopefully I end up close to the Target T
okay so I'll have a embedding for every
relation I'll have an embedding for
every entity so if this is a relation
brother then and if this is me then from
me to brother here should be all my
brothers and I know if there's a
relation sister then I go this way and
here should be embedded all my sisters
just as an example right or you know if
there's a relation you likes to it then
there is a I would learn I know
something down here and here would be
all the dishes that Ur likes to eat okay
so that's kind of the idea here right so
the idea is that you know if I have an
embedding of Obama I have an embedding
of nationality so now I say who what is
the nationality of Obama I take this I
take the vector that I learned for
nationality I move move in the space
wherever I land this is where I want his
nationality to be embedded that will be
kind of the objective function of course
it won't be spot on but that's kind of
the idea right so basically this means
that we are going to learn embeddings of
entities as well as the embeddings of
relations or vectors for this relations
with the goal that if I start at the
head I move in the direction of the
relation that is specified by the
relation I arrive at the Target and for
people who have kind of NLP backr
remember when we had this um I know in
or some time ago right there were this
word embeddings and and and people were
so fascinated that if you take a king
and move in One Direction you move to
the queen and if you take um uh um and
uh you know it was kind of consistent uh
for different kings and queens of all
different world countries kind of that
Vector in which you move was the same
for the mall or if you took a name of
the country and you looked where is the
capital embedded it was kind of the same
direction from you know China and
Beijing from USA and Washington DC for
Germany and Berlin it was all this kind
of vectors so that's kind of the one um
motivation uh for this here's the
algorithm I throw pseudo code up but the
reason I want to throw it up like show
it here is that I want to show you that
you basic the way you learn this is in
using a contrastive or triplet loss okay
so that's the concept I want to teach
you here so the way we think of this is
that basically we initialize the the
embeddings of um uniform random of of
entities and relations and then what I'm
doing is I'm basically um uh I need to
create negative samples right for every
triplet in the in the in my um in my
knowledge graph head relation tail I say
ahuh for for a for a given head and a
given relation the tail is a positive
example but the real tail is a positive
example but now I need to find a a a
negative example tail right and now that
I have a head real tail and a wrong tail
my goal in the objective function is
that the distance between head plus
relation to the real tail should be
smaller than the distance from the head
plus relation and the wrong tail and
then of course here you ask
yourself right and this is called a
contrastive loss that favors lower
distance higher score for valid triples
versus and on to have high distance um
lower lower score for um the corrupted
ones for the negative ones and that's
kind of the contrastive loss I want to
explain here yes question uh yes so in
the in line 10 orally whenever you
sample your negative sample uh you have
H Prime as well as P Prime does that
mean you're sampling for both like a
long head and a wrck tail uh because
yeah like uh good question you can do it
you can do it both ways you could say
for the head relation I want to get a
correct tail and a wrong tail the
question is what is the wrong tail if
you will pick a random entity that will
be a too easy tail so what you usually
want to do is you want to pick a tail
that is of the same type but wrong right
so if I'm going from country capital
sorry country capital off and the and
the city then I want the wrong tail to
be a different city I don't want the the
wrong tail to be a chocolate bar right
that's it's like that that won't work
right it's too easy so you want to be
kind of careful how you do this uh
negative example sampling but this is
basically you know in some sense yeah
great question how do we handle
transitive relations like if you have a
brother then he's also your brother but
the vector only points in One Direction
great question so the question is how do
you handle uh uh transitive relations uh
let me get to that we said we are going
to fill in that table that's exactly the
question I want to address next next is
is right what what is disabled to learn
and where it's clearly going to fail
okay so um now what we want to talk
about is exactly what the question was
about right um relationship in
heterogeneous graphs have different
properties some may be S symmetric like
a brother or a roommate I'm your
roommate you are also my roommate right
it has to be that way if we are
roommates um some may have uh um uh uh
inverse relations right if I am your
adviser you are my ad advise right so
it's kind of uh uh that way um this
means that you know if one exists the
other one should also exist so we can
categorize this type of relationship
patterns and ask are knowledge gra
Knowledge Graph embedding method like a
trans Z is it able is it expressive
enough to capture this type of patterns
okay so now what patterns of relations
are we interested in and here are the
four I'll talk about first one is
symmetric or anti- symmetric relations
that says if um head and tail of are
related by uh relationship R and then
tail and head should also be related by
relationship R so this is like if we are
if I'm your brother you are my brother
as well okay and uh anti-symmetric means
if H is related to T then T cannot be
related by H using the same relation
okay um then you have inverse relation
which would mean that this is like
advisor ADV z type right where whenever
uh H is an advisor of T then T is an ad
Z of H right that's uh uh what we say an
inverse relation uh then we have
composition or transitive relations
where you say if X and Y are of related
by R1 and y and z are related by uh R2
then uh uh x and z should be related by
R3 uh so if you think of this it's like
um if I'm someone's um someone's son and
they are and that person is someone
else's daughter then that person is I
know my grandmother or something like
that right uh I think I didn't say it
well but you see what I mean it's like
based on relationship the third one is
uh is determined that's what we say
composition of relationships or uh
transitive relations and then the last
one is this one to n relations where um
you can have a case where the same head
is in relation with many different Tails
so it could be a case that I can have
more than one I can have more than one
brother so there could be many tales
that satisfy this relation yes yeah does
composition assume like one order for
your operations like because your
husband's mother won't be the same as
your mother's husband no this assumes
order okay this assumes
order
okay so let's now look what TR Z allows
me to do right is it able to give me uh
to model anti- symmetric relations like
hyper type relations right and uh uh it
can it can allow me it allows me to do
that right if H is in relation with t
then T cannot be in the same relation
with r okay so this uh this is uh what
this uh allows me uh to do it also
allows me to model inverse relations by
basically saying if H is related to T
then T can be related to Edge according
to this other relation right so it's
just kind of a a vector pointing in the
opposite direction so that that I can uh
I can also do I can also do composition
right by saying if I can go from X to Y
by R1 and from y to Z by R2 then I can
also learn a relation that goes directly
from one to the other so these things
are uh naturally U naturally uh
naturally composable right um so this is
in terms uh right my mother's husband is
my father or something like that right
um so this is what we can uh what we can
what we can uh uh model but here's an
example we cannot that of a relation
that trans Z is not able to learn right
like a symmetric relation like family
roommate brother and so on right then I
cannot model symmetric relations the
only way to model them is to embed H and
T to the same spot and have r r equal to
zero right then h plus H+ R equals t and
t plus R equals H right that's the
that's the only way this would be this
would be possible so we say that you
cannot model uh symmetric relations uh
with trans Z okay so uh that's the uh
that's that's one issue and then another
issue is that transy can also not model
one to n relations when it's kind of one
to many uh relations because the only
way to to model one to many would be
that again T1 and T2 have to be uh uh
embedded at the same dot at the same
spot so there is no distinction between
these two entities right like you only
move in One Direction um and you cannot
um uh you cannot uh you cannot uh do
this because T1 and T2 will be ma into
the same Vector even though they are
different entities okay these are um
these are the reasons uh you know what
trans Z can do and what trans Z cannot
do okay so um based based on kind of
this uh intuitions failures of uh trans
Z I'll now show you a different method
that uh people have invented that will
allow us to fix uh some of these issues
okay so now we we kind of complete
completed the first line of that table
and we are now moving uh to the to the
second line uh of the table which is the
approach that that is called
transar um right and the way trans Z
models translation of any relation uh in
the same uh embedding space the question
is can we design a new space for each
relation and do the translation in the
relationship specific space okay that's
what transar tries to do
so transar is going to model entities as
vectors in the entity space but model
each relation as a vector in the uh
relation space right where
um R will be uh K
dimensional um and uh we will actually
going to have then uh a matrix that is
going to map from this K dimensional
space back into the D dimensional space
in which the uh entities are embedded so
we are going to have this projection
Matrix uh that's the idea for transar
okay so transar models entities as
vectors in the entity space that is the
dimensional and models each relation as
a vector in the relation space um with
MSA bar being this this projection
Matrix that is uh relation specific
right um so the
the scoring function so the way we are
going to kind of measure the distance
between uh uh head and tail for a given
relationship uh R is is the following is
we are going to um apply uh rot uh
relation specific uh projection uh uh to
The Entity H that's why I have it here
uh we are going to apply the same uh uh
projection to The Entity T and then we
are going to to move according to the
vector R okay so here basically for
every relation we are allowed to to um
to uh to kind of linearly uh morph the
space um uh in a relation specific way
okay so the idea is that you know maybe
the entities uh in the original space
are embedded this way but then our
projection Matrix is going to embed them
differently and then the relation
embedding vector tell me how to move
from head uh to the tail that's the
that's the idea so here I'm learning uh
three things I'm learning the embeddings
of entities I'm learning the relation
Vector R and I'm learning the projection
Matrix for every relation that's the
that's the idea so now let's reason
about what this is going uh right and
just maybe in terms of how do I learn
this I basically use this this is my
objective function right it's it's
essent it's an analogous to uh to the TR
Z1 where we had the same we said the
that the distance between H+ R and T has
to be small um but in this case in this
case I'm using this uh projection Matrix
so it's essentially the same objective
function that I'm trying to uh that I'm
trying to optimize just that I add uh
Matrix M as part of the learning as well
so um so now uh what is interesting is
that in this case I may actually be able
to model um symmetric uh symmetric
relationships because uh transar will
allow me to do this because uh The
Matrix uh M will allow me to uh map from
the two entities from the space of
entities uh to the to the S kind of to
the same spot in the relation uh
specific uh uh space so this means that
we can map a H and T to the same
location in the space uh of relation R
um and H and T are still different
entities in the uh in the original space
right so I can learn this type of
mapping and uh I will be able to handle
symmetric relations uh the the something
that TR z uh was not able to do I am
also able to handle um anti-symmetric
relations this is actually the same as
in that trans Z can do where um uh um
you know I can learn a projection that
will kind of keep the entities apart so
um I won't be able to come uh back to it
okay so that's the same as what trans Z
was able to do um now how about one to n
relations right one to n Rel one to many
relations means that one entity is
related to many other entities according
to the same relation uh uh again
um uh transends R will be able to do
this because we can learn this
projection Matrix so that different
targets uh different tails get mapped to
the same point so the idea is right if I
in my original space I'll have H T1 and
T2 um it is it's possible to learn a
projection Matrix that Maps both of them
to the same point point so in this
relation space um you know now I said
from H according to R there's multiple
entities here even though in the
original space for some other
relationship I'm still able to
distinguish this entities yes can you
make a generaliz that if a embedding
method can handle symmetric relations
then it can handle one
Rel so the question was can you make a
general claim that if a method can
handle symmetric sorry um yeah symmetric
relations then it can handle one two
many Rel Rel ations uh I I I I don't
think so my my answer my answer would be
no uh but for a proof maybe we can talk
after the okay good thank you for the
question yes so why do we use just a
linear transformation from The Entity
space to the relationship why don't we
do like an MLP or something ahuh good
question so the question is why are we
using a linear transformation why
wouldn't we do um a nonlinear um a
nonlinear transformation
uh I guess you could um I mean I think
you could you would learn an MLP that
would basically take these coordinates
and learn how to how to transform them
um you know I'm trying to come up with a
reason why that would be a bad idea
um it's a good it's a good question um
um my sense does anyone see why this
would be a bad
idea competition expensive mean yeah I
don't know like we could you could see
whether this is possible to learn now
you are learning one kind of separate M
MLP uh uh for like it will be a very
complicated learning Loop because you
will learn the embeddings of entities
then you will want to learn the MLP
you'll want to learn the
R so it's a good question how how you
will whether this would kind of work in
practice but if somebody gives you an
MLP that works and the embeddings yeah I
there's no problem with that but good
good question I you know be fun to try
um cool okay so this is one too many and
then in terms of inverse relations again
uh this is uh uh this is kind of easy to
see because it's trans are is just a
generalization of trans Z so if the
projection Matrix is for two relations
uh uh two two um inverse relations is
the same then basically you know one
relation Vector is an inverse of the
other relation vector and you get this
the same way we got it in uh in transar
uh in trans Z okay and then the last
thing to discuss is this composition of
relations um and the way the way perhaps
uh to see this um is that uh I'll give
you some kind of visual proof for high
level intuition why this is why this is
possible and the idea that trans are
models are triple with linear functions
which are chainable right kind of linear
functions are composable so um
everything will work that's the that's
the high level intuition and uh here uh
here here I have a a longer um a longer
a longer proof that maybe in the
interest of time that I that I um spent
at the beginning talking about last
year's lecture that was slightly
different um I will skip but the way the
way you can you can do this is first you
need to Define this kernel space of a of
a of a matrix and then you know you can
you can say aha what is composition of
relations if you know if X and Y are
related to with R1 and Y and Z by R2
then I want to show that Y and Z
according to R3 um uh is is possible and
basically you start writing it out
according to our uh to our linear
algebra with this projection matrices um
and then um and then
uh and then that will uh uh and then you
can basically uh Define or come up with
the answer that because you can because
these matrices are linear operators uh
you can you can chain them and get the
correct answer at the end yes basically
two Vector spaces like the space of
entities and the space of relations and
all these rules are examining like
injective subjective or
bjective can I give you that way
um can you can you clar like can you ask
again if this two so basically like the
space of entities is Rd the Stace of
relations is r k so it's just true
Vector spaces corre right so therefore
we're looking at composition like of
linear Maps exactly a composition of
linear Maps across these two Vector
space so then if it's one 2 N that would
be looking at if something's subjective
and then we can think about injective or
if it's bjective correct you can you can
that's maybe another way to say it is
that basically you have two Vector
spaces one is a d dimensional and I
think the other one you said is a k
dimensional um and uh you are basically
learning at looking at compositions
across these two and you are looking at
this as you said bjective subjective uh
or injective um uh relationships across
the space so would that be related to
the earlier two questions about um what
earlier earlier our friend asked um if
it's one to n would it also be symmetric
that would mean just because it's
rejective it doesn't mean it could be
bjective exactly well would that answer
this question as well about the MLP
because we're looking at um like linear
composition ma between therefore you
can't use MLP exactly that's a great
Point actually I was thinking of exactly
the same um uh great observation
actually so where your MLP would break
is here right so that's you would lose
um composition of relations with with
with the MLP so that's that that's the
place it could break so yeah great great
part exactly exactly cool uh good I
continue so this was um uh our second
method that's uh called transar uh and
kind of defines these two uh Vector
spaces uh and kind of maps these
projection matrices uh from one from one
to the other what I want to do next is
talk talk about uh the third method in
this um in this space called this mol
okay um and this here is the the idea
behind this is this notion of bilinear
modeling right so far our scoring
function was just a ukian distance or it
was an L2 or L2 distance in this uh
between the the embedding of the head
comma relation and the embedding of the
Target and we wanted to minimize that uh
distance um uh another line of work that
kind of is is a bit different is is
trying to adopt what what what is called
bilinear modeling and in this m entities
and relations uh are using vectors uh in
uh RK but the scoring function that uh
that uh measures the distance between
head and tail according to the relation
R um will have the following form where
you are going to basically go over uh uh
the individual coordinates of H R and T
multiply them to together and sum them
up so the way the way you can uh you can
uh uh think of this is that basically
you have the head you have a
relation you have a head and a tail you
have a relation you you multiply these
things together coordinate twice and sum
them up and that is your score okay so
now we defined um we defined a different
scoring function um and we are still
going to have a head relation and a tail
embedding as we had it in
trans Z just the scoring function is now
different all right so um the intuition
for the scoring function is that it can
be viewed as a cosine similarity between
H time R um and T where uh in our case h
* R um would be uh defined as a as a
summation uh of uh H subi and R R subi
right so the idea would be that
basically basically um if you have
um if you have your uh Target T2 and you
have your target T1 then um you can you
can basically uh think of uh uh of the
um of this Vector a h * R um and when
you multiply it with t that's basically
coordinate way wise um uh uh uh
multiplication uh and uh and a summation
okay so that's the way um to uh uh to
think of this so let's now look at um
what this this m uh allows you to do so
let's first look at one to many
relations so here I have head relation
tail one head relation tail two um and
you know can can this m uh uh model this
um it basically um can because um it can
it can put uh tail one and tail two um
in such a way that basically the the
cosine uh uh distance um between between
this uh these vectors um uh will be um
will be uh will be equal okay so that's
the that's the first uh the first thing
the second thing is to go and ask about
symmetric uh relations here you know
this is again this brother type uh
relation the way this m can uh uh uh uh
can naturally can naturally do this is
because basically our um our um scoring
function um is the same regardless of uh
head and tail right so basically
multiplication is um um you know the
order uh the order in which I multiply
numbers doesn't matter right so I'll get
the same score if I'm scoring head
relation t or ifine scoring tail
relation head so I will naturally uh get
that of course because I get this
property I then um cannot get the uh
anti-symmetric property because this
mold cannot model anti-symmetric uh
relations right because the score of
head relation tail is the same as score
of tail relation head uh uh this means
uh um uh the the the uh score
of head and tail and the score of tail
and relation will always be the same so
you cannot uh distinguish uh distinguish
the two right so you cannot say if head
is in relation r with tail then tail
cannot be in the same relation with uh
with r that will you know it will always
uh be symmetric it won't be able to to
capture this type of
anti-symmetry um and then the same the
same thing is with inverse relations
where you would want to be able to
enforce relationships with where if head
is in relation R2 with tail then tail is
in relation of R1 with the head and
again because of this uh argument on the
previous slide uh this m won't be able
to model this type of relations because
uh if it does model inverse uh relations
then it would mean that R1 and R2 have
to be the same have to be kind of the
same Vector but ially this does not make
sense because embedding of advisor
should be kind of shouldn't be the same
or should be different than the
embedding of the advise z um so that's
what I wanted to say about modeling
inverse relations um and the last thing
I want to uh address is the notion of
composition uh of relations okay so here
the question is can I learn can this
mult learn patterns where this kind of
R1 uh you know composition or transitive
relation
um and the intuition here is that this
mol defines a hyper plane for each head
relation pair and the union of
hyperplanes induced by the um multihop
relationship across multiple uh
relations cannot be expressed uh as a
single hyper plane right so you cannot
kind of compose these uh hyperplanes uh
step step by step and maintain the and
maintain the hyper plane so you won't be
able to learn kind of compositions where
you can go uh um or or um transitivity
uh across uh relationships okay so um
this is and I have a detailed um
detailed derivation um um uh here here
here as well where basically what we are
going the the um the um what you are
basically able to show is that the the
composition of you know two relationship
cannot be expressed using a single uh a
single hyper plate and the detailed
derivation uh will go would go in the
following way that we would pick some y
uh such that the scoring function of X Y
according to relation one is greater
than zero and then for example um let's
call this uh Y2 and then we are going to
say that then Y2 times some other
relation R is kind of going to define
the new um hyper plane and then we will
be uh observing um what is uh what is
happening um as we now uh pick uh
another uh in our case another um uh y
such that the relation Y and that Y is
greater than zero let's call this uh y
Y3 and then y * relation two will Define
the new
um the new the new hyper plane okay and
then basically now if you have the two
hyper planes defi divide defined by Y2
and Y3 and now you know combining them
um together uh for you know for all uh
Z's that are in this uh Shadow uh Shadow
area um there uh you know the question
is does there exist y between this Y2
and Y3 such that the score of Y and Z
according to the relation uh two um is
uh greater uh greater than uh greater
than uh greater than zero right and uh
what you are uh going to find is that
you know for that basically you cannot
um you cannot uh find uh find um uh uh
uh such uh such a case where this would
be um where this would be possible right
so a way to look at it is that basically
according to the composition of uh
relations we would also want the score
according now to R3 between x and z
right to be greater to be greater than
zero right for every Z that is in this
um Shadow area right but this is this
inherently cannot be cannot be done or
expressed as a single hyper plane
defined by X and R3
uh no matter what R3 is right so
basically this means that in this uh um
uh this m you are not able to express uh
transitive uh transitive relations um
this is quite interesting because this
this m as I'm going to show you later um
some people like in some knowledge
graphs it works really well so it
becomes you know a good question um what
kind of method to apply to a given
domain or to a given uh Knowledge Graph
yes a question the key difference
between this method we're learning in
transar CR a seems to be the scoring
exactly function and that seems to then
imply why we can't have this composition
why there's a limitation opposition is
there a way to pick a scoring method
such that it has many of the beneficial
properties of this without the drawback
of uh composition being unavailable
great so it's a good uh so I'll repeat
your question and uh um and also your
observation observation is that
basically um what we are doing here this
is very similar to our 10 Z method right
we are learning an embedding of every
every entity and every relation but what
we changed was the scoring function
right in the transy our scoring function
was the distance between H + R and T uh
here our scoring function is this
product of product and Su of this uh
coordinates and because we changed the
scoring function uh we get certain
properties for free while uh losing uh
other properties um as I think you are
going to see at the end in the final
table um it's actually the trans are
that checks the most of those check
check marks right where we were learning
these projection matrices between the
the two uh the two vectors spaces um
that's that's what I would say about
this yes short question so we were
talking today mostly about the
transductive setting for most of this
learning but let's say in real world
application we saw these These are
massive massive massive massive networks
so don't we want to basically find a
method that we can do on a small part of
the network so we can generalize so
let's say transar we need the we'll need
the M Matrix for all these entries right
so that would be a non-comp
computationally feasable matrix good
question so the question is uh you know
uh these methods are transductive it
means we have to learn an embedding for
every M for every entity separately
won't this be
computationally expensive um the answer
is yes uh the the I would say from one
reason why transactive is okay is
because these graphs we don't think of
them as Dynamic we don't think of this
as data we think of this as as knowledge
in some sense and and you know the set
of entities is kind of fixed the set of
relationships is also fixed and you are
trying to infer let's say the edges you
trying to embed the the entities
according to the uh to the relationships
AC uh in which they are so actually in
terms of scalability this is challenging
but it's not that challenging because
you can kind of distribute these
entities uh across different machines
and there is a very nice uh package uh
open sourced by Facebook called Big
graph if you just Google that on GitHub
you can basically get uh get a system
that will allow you to embed essentially
arbitrarily knowledge graphs and
internally Facebook let's say was using
this this this type of technology to
embed all the entities in their
Knowledge Graph and use that for
recommendations so people have put
immense resources and energy to be able
to scale this up uh to the Facebook
scale uh and then they open source so
you can do this and a lot of people when
they want to start playing in industrial
settings with kind of graph machine
learning use cases the first thing we do
to would be to use this uh big graph
package uh that's that's on Facebook uh
on GitHub okay cool that answer the
question okay great thank you super so
now um we the last the last method today
and then U and then wrap up and this
method that I want to talk today the
last one is called complex right and uh
it's based on this SM um but complex is
going to embed uh entities and relations
in the complex Vector space right so not
in the real but in the in the complex
right um so now the way um you can think
of this and what you are uh getting what
you are getting when you are in the in
the complex space you get this notion of
of the complex conjugate right if I have
a a point uh in the in the with a
complex embedding that has the the real
and the imaginary axis then there is
also exists a um a conjugate of that
point where basically if I had before A+
b i now I have uh a minus uh b i okay so
that's the uh that's the uh what you get
here um when you think about uh complex
uh complex arithmetics and trying to
think about how would I embed um things
in the complex space right so here um
the way the way we think of this is uh U
is a is a point in the complex space and
the way is the position of it is defined
in two ways is defined by the um
embedding of a and it's defined by the
embedding of B uh and both are K
dimensional okay so that's the way um
that's the way uh to think of this uh
but of course what is going to um work
differently is now the scoring function
and the way the scoring function is
going to
work is that uh is that now I'm going
when I'm doing my um uh my soring
function is going to be defined this way
right so I'm going uh to multiply H and
R but I'm going to multiply that with
the conjugate of uh T and then whatever
is the result I'm only going to take uh
the real part uh of that and that will
be my uh my uh my example of the score
uh for a given relation had and the tail
okay that's the that's the that's the
idea of how complex is going to work
okay so um now let's go and look what
this will allow us to model first let's
look at U anti- symmetric relations um
and uh um you know the claim is that
complex can model anti-symmetric
relations um and the the the idea is
that you know the model is expressive
enough to be able to learn a high value
of the scoring function uh for uh uh
when you when you are uh multiplying H
uh and the and the conjugate of T and
AOW value of the function where you are
multiplying t with the conjugate uh of H
okay so due to the symmetric uh modeling
uh of using uh complex uh conjugate
right so this is this means that we will
be able to model um complex uh um
complex
relationships uh how about s symmetric
relationships right roommate brother and
so on you are able to do uh to do that
as well and here I have a bit of uh a
bit of algebra right so you are asking
what's the score between of r h and T is
and is that the same as the score of R T
and H and you can uh the way you can um
you can uh uh derive this is to say oh
this is the real of this product you can
uh take the product uh you can take the
product out you can then take uh R um
which is U which is a uh uh a a real
vector and uh just take the the real of
the of the H and T which are which are
which are uh complex um if you if you uh
uh do it this way then then uh you can
move uh the uh the conjugate from T to H
as well and then basically expand it
back uh to get the EMB to get to the
scoring function of T comma H so the key
the key step is this step where you
basically is the equivalence from here
uh to here and then it's just expanding
it back to to uh what the scoring what
the scoring function is so this is for
uh showing symmetric
relations um last what is interesting
about complex is that you can also do
inverse uh inverse relations and the way
you can do uh inverse relations Is that
R and um uh that R1 is just a conjugate
of R is a complex conjugate of R of of
R2 right and the idea here is right is
in this kind of um uh when we talked
about cosine uh cosine
distance or cosine similarity where um
where 90° is exactly the angle um at
which uh things are at the at the at the
maximum at the maximum distance and
that's why um this is uh this is the
case here and if you think about if you
go back to my original picture right
what kind of the the angle between these
two vectors vectors of few and the
conjugate of you is also um 90° right
and the dot product between these guys
uh will be uh will be zero if you think
of it in the in kind of the the ukian
way okay so that that's the reason about
uh inverse relations and then the last
thing I want to talk is about
composition um uh as well as uh uh one
to many relations and here basically I
can just say that complex shares the
same property with this SM you cannot
model compositional relations and you
cannot model model one to many uh
relations using it so now to bring
everything together and kind of
summarize it here is a one slide summary
of today's lecture of different methods
what um that how do these methods differ
these methods differ on how the
embedding is determined is it determined
um you know the are we embedding hdnr in
the real space are like this was in
trans Z in trans R we had H T and R
embedded
in um uh embedded in actually H and T
were embedded in D dimensional R was
embedded in um um uh D dimensional and
then we had the the projection Matrix
that mapped from the uh entity space to
the relation space and then for this mol
uh and complex we um in this mol we used
the embeddings that were in the reals
for complex we use the embeddings that
were in the complex space and then the
scoring functions uh uh we were using
were different right for Trans Z it's a
simple let's say here ukian distance the
L2 Norm between head plus relation minus
tail so basically the distance between
the head plus relation and the tail um
in the transar we had this projection
matrices involved but it's still let's
say ukian
distance in this mold we defined the we
find we Define this kind of notion of
cosine distance and in complex uh we we
changed further definition we kind of
adopted the thism distance function but
added the the um uh uh uh we extended it
uh in the following way and then what
was different right is that we looked at
this symmetric anti- symmetric inverse
composite or also called transitive
relations and one to many relations and
this is how different methods compare to
what they are able to uh what kind of of
relations they are able to model uh
that's what I wanted to say and I also
going to um to have a few more slides
with practical tips but I'm happy now to
take questions oh yeah I had a question
about the antisymmetric case for
complex is there like a complex
conjugate
interpretation for proving that that one
works just felt like for symmetric for
inverse that was a really nice complex
you get interpretation
that I didn't get that for anti
symmetric
case uh good point why don't we why
don't we then go back and look at it
together after the lecture okay good
anything else people would like to
ask um if not let me just uh a a few
more things to say so the in practice
right like I I gave you these methods
and you're like it's clear what I should
be using it has all the check marks
beautiful um you know it seems this mold
you shouldn't really be using has the
most uh captures the list of these
properties and so on but actually you
know the the the real world is a bit
more um is a bit more complicated and it
actually turns out that different
knowledge graphs will have very
different drastically different uh
relation patterns kind of prop relations
with different properties so generally
there is kind of not a one best
embedding that works for all all um all
different uh uh all different knowledge
graphs so many times it's good to
actually go into the knowledge graph see
what are the types of relationships you
have try to quantify them understand
them and then um and then choose your uh
method what people like to use is
usually first run trans Z because it's
so simple and so easy it's kind of the
easiest to learn the easiest to to to uh
to make stable um it's kind of the the
very natural very interpretable very
easy to try so people would usually
start with trans z um and then you know
you can move uh um you can move to more
uh complex uh complex uh uh uh models
like um complex rot a uh thism um and uh
and so on um transy is going to work
well especially if the your T your graph
doesn't have too many symmetric uh
relations okay um so kind of to
summarize uh today's lecture we talked
about link prediction or Knowledge Graph
completion as one of the uh important
task in this field of Knowledge Graph um
embeddings we talked about definition of
a of a Knowledge Graph and how knowledge
graphs are being used to uh serve in
information but that knowledge graphs
are extremely incomplete um and PE and
people uh usually want to complete them
make them more robust um what is also a
very useful way to use a knowledge graph
is that you can use it as a scaffold for
some external nodes to connect to it and
then learn a GNN that you know goes
between your data graph and between your
background knowledge graph this
especially very useful in uh biomedical
applications where you have the
background biomedical knowledge graph of
your of your biological entities but
maybe then you have a patient node that
links to different parts of the
knowledge graph and then you can start
thinking about learning um let's say
gnns that are going to go from patient
down to the knowledge graph propagate
across the knowledge graph and go back
to the patient and do this kind of
triangular information passing and
that's a very effective way how you can
let's say reason about patients by
exploiting the background knowledge the
background knowledge graph that you have
about human biology so that's maybe one
way to think about is that knowledge
graphs are very helpful either to serve
information and then you want to use
these embeddings to complete them
sometimes people apply this knowledge
graph embedding techniques also to their
data graphs I mentioned the example of
uh of Facebook and the big graph package
they developed um but I think when these
things work also really well is when you
bring your you know your data entities
and connect them with your background
knowledge your knowledge graph entities
this this example of patients and uh you
know underlying uh biomedical knowledge
graphs uh being being an example uh
today we talked about you know the the
the lecture today was was quite dense
and we talked about four different
methods kind of trans Z that that's easy
and natural we talked about transar
that's a bit more advanced but based on
the same um same intuition and then this
mol and complex that kind of changed
this uh uh scoring function uh and they
all use kind of different embedding
spaces and they have different um uh uh
expressiveness but so this is what I
wanted to show today and then next week
um on Tuesday I'm actually going to uh
kind of enrich
uh this notion of how do I do link
prediction in knowledge graphs and we'll
talk about this kind of multihop Link
prediction or basically being able to
reason and answer arbitrary queries over
incomplete Knowledge Graph so we will be
given an a a knowledge graph and a
logical query and the question will be
can you find all the entities that
satisfy that logical query um that's
what we are going to uh learn uh about
on Tuesday um you know let's finish here
but if people have questions please come
come here and we can uh we can talk uh
thank you so
much